hey everybody i am dave rubin
this is the reuben report direct message
for april 21st
2021 and obviously there's a lot going
on in the world
and i think this is going to be our most
densely packed
episode ever yesterday i thought we were
going to do our longest show ever but i
was able to keep it
somewhat tight but i am going to do
my best today to give you guys
actual stats to show you some things
about media manipulation
show you some things about politicians
fanning the flame
and also show you how when you defund
the police which is seemingly
what this is all about that actually
crime goes up we are going to source
things you will see where they're
sourced from on the screen i will read
the sources and my hope is that we will
clip some of this stuff and you'll be
able to share it
with friends and family because uh even
though
uh you know let's say the left broadly
speaking got the result that they wanted
yesterday
it doesn't seem like we're doing
anything close to unity and healing
right i mean if anything it seems like
now they're more emboldened
to continue to burn down the system and
actually we're gonna play a couple
quotes from democrat politicians
saying in effect just that so this is
gonna be a bit of a sobering
episode i suppose uh but i'm going to do
my best not to add flames
not to add fuel to the fire and inflame
the situation any further and hopefully
by the end of the half hour or so you
will feel like you're armed with a
little bit
more knowledge in how to have these
conversations because everything
that i'm seeing online right now pretty
much
is just an absolute assault on truth and
an assault on stats and information
which by the way is in many ways why
there's
a push for them to get rid of math in
school and right we should we shouldn't
have traditional math of 2 plus
2 equals 4 we should have this new math
and we should look at things a little
bit differently
and all that because they don't want you
to look at statistics because statistics
don't fit
the narrative so we're gonna hit all
that so the three things that really
we're gonna
cover today are gonna be reactions to
the trial mostly from democrat
politicians who again in essence got the
result that they wanted right
and got what he prayed for that's what
we showed you yesterday but uh
apparently it's still not enough for him
and certainly not
enough for aoc and nancy pelosi and a
bunch of the others then we're going to
show you
a whole slew of police
stats related to race from
real sources and again hopefully you can
take them and do something with them
in the conversations that you're having
in your life and then the third story
will be about defunding the police and
what that has done
in the cities that we have done it and
hint
spoiler alert it ain't good okay before
we get to any of that guys
i want to talk to you about ancestry.com
did your great-grandmother work hard to
raise her children and keep her family
together i know mine did
did your family survive natural
disasters to rebuild and start anew was
there a health care worker in your
family's past who cared for another
generation facing a pandemic
or ancestors our ancestors were ordinary
people
who lived through extraordinary
situations something we can all
understand today
challenging times are nothing new
neither are resilient people
learning about the struggles and
adversity your family went through can
bring you closer to your own family
today as you share
stories and form new bonds ancestry
helps you search billions of records to
learn more about the ancestors who came
through remarkable challenges
so you could be here today yeah that u.s
of america it's pretty good
uh you can find details about their
lives see what they did to earn a living
in their census record or see their
actual signature on a military record
as they signed up to fight for our
country learning their stories helps you
find a connection to what they went
through and how they stood
strong through hardships and struggles
when you get closer to your ancestors by
hearing their stories you'll have a new
way to get closer to your family
their strength in every family story
learn more about yours at
ancestry.com head to my url ancestry.com
reuben to start your free trial that's
ancestry.comruben and now back to me
okay so
we're gonna show you a whole bunch of
reaction
videos right now these are mostly
democrats or
or left-leaning public figures who again
they got
the result they wanted right and we can
all discuss as i said yesterday
we can all discuss whether we have a
problem now with the jury system
we can discuss whether we have a problem
with policing we can discuss whether
politicians before trials come to an end
saying things actually affect the juries
i mean imagine if you were one of the 12
jurors on this thing
and you felt that you might be doxxed
that you might be found out
i was even thinking about it this way
like ethically just sort of ethically
morally
and philosophically let's say you were
one of those 12 people
and you let's say said you know actually
the amount of fentanyl in his system
this that the other thing
the knee whatever the specifics might be
i'm just doing a little thought
experiment here
let's say you were like you know what i
actually don't think he's guilty on all
charges maybe he's guilty of two of
three or one of three whatever it is
but you felt there was a pretty decent
chance you were going to be doxxed at
the end of this
and you've got the president of the
united states saying i pray
for the result that we want you know a
conviction obviously and you've got
maxine waters out there with her burn it
down
sentiment and all that i just think
ethically
morally philosophically whatever it is
um
people might be encouraged to
uh defend their own lives and the lives
of their families so we we have so many
problems because we've sort of condoned
the idea that if you don't get the
result you want you can still be violent
and actually as of last night
even if you do get the result you want
in a trial you can still be violent and
that we can threaten people and
potentially dox them
and everything else so let's just roll
through a bunch of videos here
this is joe biden the president
explaining how the protests
unified us with peace and purpose the
murder of george floyd
launched the summer a protest we hadn't
seen since the civil rights year in the
60s
protests that unified people of every
race and generation
in peace and with purpose to say enough
enough
enough of this senseless killings
today today's verdict
is a step forward no one should be above
the law
and today's verdict sends that message
but it's not
enough we can't stop here
in order to deliver real change and
reform
we can and we must do more to reduce the
likelihood that tragedies like this will
ever happen and occur again
okay so there's a couple things there so
first off he says that the protests over
the summer and basically what he means
for the last year
that they unified us i mean do we feel
more unified does anyone feel more
unified today than we felt yesterday
and yesterday did we feel more unified
than we did six months ago i don't think
so i actually think in many cases this
is tearing us apart
because these protests are laden with
violence and burning things down now the
people that believe
a lot of what joe biden says don't see a
lot of that stuff because they don't
show you
a lot of that stuff he also says enough
of the senseless killing so we're going
to get to the stats on police shootings
in just a second
but i do think it's important that i
show you this one right now this is from
the washington post
okay now the washington post i believe
is considered a reputable source on
these things
the washington post database of fatal
police shootings in 2019
cites nine unarmed black victims
and 19 unarmed white victims of fatal
police shootings okay so there were 10
more fatal police shootings related to
unarmed people
that were of white people than black
people only nine
unarmed black people were killed by
police in 2019 now
that we could argue that's nine too many
but when they say things like this
enough of the senseless killings notice
they never
say numbers they never actually give you
stats because they love
narrative not actual information so
we're gonna get
on to more of those numbers in just a
sec but i think it was worth
mentioning that right there because he's
talking about senseless killings
and it's like well actually there aren't
that many of them i know a lot of people
believe that there are but there just
simply
aren't and when he says that we've come
together over this thing i don't think
that we've quite
come together over it and actually let's
look at aoc right now because she's
basically saying it
this doesn't end until
we address the massive systemic
institutional racism in the united
states
that leads and accepts black people
our black brothers and sisters our brown
brothers and sisters
our native brothers and sisters as less
than human
that's literally what it is is that
we're willing to accept violence
against some communities as a necessary
cost for
safety and we talk about these
conversations of safety
safety from what from whom
because
what makes me feel safe is being housed
what makes me feel safe is when i'm not
going to be thrown out of my home
what makes me feel safe is guaranteed
health care
man well first off i want to
congratulate aoc because we played a
video of her yesterday where
she had complete word salad nothing she
said made anything close
to any sort of sensible sentence so
i'll give you credit where it's due lady
um but
meaning that she did string together a
couple words it kind of made sense there
but it was all drivel everything that
she said there
first off we do not have systemic and
institutional racism
there are no laws in the united states
that are racist
against any one person by the way i do
believe that the woke left that the
progressives will
instigate laws that will be racist
against people they will start having
anti-white laws this is not a crazy
conspiracy theory
they're four quotas already we
know that they don't want a certain
amount of asian people because they're
over-represented at harvard well these
are the places where do
all these bad ideas that leak out into
society they start at the university
level
so if you're going to say we in the
government we are going to have
diversity and inclusion departments
where we are going to hire based on the
color of skin then you are going to
discriminate against a certain set of
people which in most cases will be white
people right it will mostly be white
people it will be asian people
as well obviously um so there is no
systemic and institutional racism and
what she's really saying there is though
even though we got the result we wanted
meaning the system worked
that they found derek shoving guilty of
killing george floyd right now it'll go
to appeal and everything else but the
system itself
worked but that's not enough because
what she in essence is saying we are
here to disassemble the state
don't take my word for it take their
word for it they believe
this place is fundamentally evil and by
the way they never go anywhere and they
still want everyone to come here
so everything she says is complete
and utter nonsense she also says what
makes me feel safe
is housing and health care so she's
telling you it has this has nothing to
do with the
death of george floyd she's talking
about this idea
of which again the system just did what
exactly what she wanted to do
but now we've got to move on well the
system worked this time but as we're
burning it down we also have to make
sure
everyone has housing and health care now
we could have a in a normal time we
could have a completely sensible debate
on what we should do about homelessness
on what we should do about health care
but they are here to burn it down
it's obvious speaking of burning it down
let's listen to
race huckster al sharpton
[Music]
[Applause]
before we say anything
we're going to have a prayer because
young people white and black
some castigated many that are here
tonight marched
and kept watching and kept going right
many of them looked down on but they
kept marching
and wouldn't let this die and this is
an assurance to them that if we don't
give up
that we can win some rounds but the war
and the fight is not over just two days
from now
we're going to have to deal with the
funeral
of dante wright the war and the fight is
not over now let's flash
back let's go back a couple day decades
to martin luther king jr
and you know that old school saying that
he didn't want his kids to be judged
by their color of their skin but by the
content of their character
that was good and that was a march to
equality let's get rid of whatever
vestiges of old jim crow laws there were
like let's do those things so that
people have true equality and you guys
know my feelings
they are now promising something called
equity which has nothing to do with the
quality and in many ways is the most
anti-american thing that there is which
is why they would like to disassemble
america but he's talking about the war
there and then he mentions uh dante
wright
now dante wright is the other uh
incident that we showed you a couple
days ago
he was pulled over it turns out there
was a warrant for his rest he was being
handcuffed he broke away the officer
thought
apparently she says 26-year veteran that
she was using a taser
but instead she shot him he died he did
resist arrest
anyway the point of all the details of
that and i also think it's dangerous
when we start
unpacking all of every little detail of
all these things because we get lost
in that which the the greater idea here
is
is that al sharpton's telling you he's
here for the war and there is no tragedy
that this guy
cannot uh make worse uh by the way
candace owens was on tucker carlson last
night and she's getting a ton of hate
uh for basically telling the truth but
it turns out that george floyd had
three times the amount of fentanyl that
it typically takes to kill a person in
his system
i'm just putting that out there for
context when they tell you these things
like
it's like somehow me saying that that
makes me bad does that make me a racist
like
that's just a fact but it's not really
something that you're hearing normally
but if you don't think that they're
using george floyd in the most twisted
perverse way listen to nancy pelosi
we all saw it on tv we saw it happen
and thank god the jury
validated what we saw what we saw
so again thank you george floyd
for sacrificing your life for justice
for being there to call out to your mom
how heartbreaking was that
call out for your mom i can't breathe
but because of you
and because of thousands millions of
people around the
world who came out for justice
your name will always be synonymous with
justice
thank you george floyd thank you george
floyd for dying
i mean she's disgusting she is a
disgusting human being
i'm sorry like what talk about the worst
sort of pandering
self-serving politician you could
possibly ever imagine and she also when
she repeatedly says
you know in essence thank god we got the
result that we wanted we all saw it on
tv
you know the thing is about a trial is
you have the presumption of innocence we
have due process we have a
jury of your peers all of the things
that i know i know that they're against
all of these things and i know that
they're trying to destroy all these
things so even rationalizing with them
about it doesn't really matter but like
just because you
see something on tv and it makes you
feel a certain way doesn't mean that
that's exactly how the judicial system
should work but this is completely
consistent with their message but then
of course what happened and it doesn't
take a genius to figure this out
was remember they got the jury decision
that they wanted right they got the
conviction that they wanted again it's
going to go to
uh it's gonna go to all sorts of further
courts down the line now and it'll be
appealed than everything else but they
basically got what they wanted
but it was obvious that violence was
still coming and that if you keep
feeding this thing you're actually just
strengthening it so there's there's two
odd things here because one is
you can just stay quiet and you're
feeding it and then there's a whole
other set of people that even if you
give it what it wants
what it supposedly wants that they're
going to feed it as well so we're just
going to show you a bunch of
compilations of black lives matter
demonstrations across
the country we've got some i believe
there's some new york city i think there
might be some dc in seattle and portland
attacking police officers attacking
random people at restaurants
attacking trucks like just it just i
mean
believe me we could have shown you this
for the next five hours here's just a
random sampling
from the country from last night after
what these people
purported to want to happen happened
we're not we're never going to be
satisfied black lives matter isn't a
trend it's a movement
black lives matter forever okay so we're
not going to stop just because we got
one conviction
let me tell you the only reason this
system
this capitalist system remains intact
is because the democrats and republicans
are working together to maintain it
they'll let us burn this whole mother to
the ground we want to give us some
systemic change
derek shaman's police department burned
to the ground so we have to remember
those people are still facing charges
for arson
we have to remember them who just set us
on the map once
again because that was epic
[Music]
we don't want you here we don't want you
we don't want you here
we don't want you we don't want your
money
white man
[Music]
this has been declared an unlawful
assembly
[Applause]
all right so i assure you we could have
shown you a ton more if you're
interested in seeing more videos
throughout the country
uh follow andy know on twitter who's
posting a ton of this stuff the last one
there which is
just a brutal assault on a police
officer that was in portland and talk
about
dystopian i mean as you hear you know
the sound in the back and the officer
get off the street et cetera et cetera i
mean it sounds like a dystopian
movie also the one with the truck before
that which i think was new york city
it's like that was just a random trucker
who had driven down a street who's
trying to do his job
and they're attacking him and there's a
million of those the one before that was
a
just a family uh eating at a mexican
restaurant
the point is that even if every single
thing that
that those self-proclaimed marxists and
communists
are saying is correct let's say it's all
correct and just
let's say america is an evil patriarchal
capitalist
horrible death-bringing awful state
let's say it's all true would the best
way to bring about
change be to attack innocent people
attack people
trying to go out to dinner and do their
jobs and everything else like
what is it that you think these people
are going to bring to society do you get
it
and and what's unfortunate here is
you've got nancy pelosi you've got
al sharpton you've now have joe biden
and kamala harris
and and virtually all of the democrats
where
is a sane democrat please show me one
i will gladly have them on the show i
will do it with no notes
and no intentions other than giving them
a platform to share their beliefs
where are the decent liberals they are
all completely
gone these the inmates are running the
asylum when you watch these videos
it should be chilling to you it should
be chilling because we are starting
to go from online mobs to real mobs and
i did a video
that's about five years old uh it was
something about how online culture is
becoming mainstream culture you can
probably if you search reuben reporter
dave rubin online culture is becoming
mainstream culture
you can hear me doing a four minute i
wrote it out actually and read it off
the prompter because i wanted to get it
right
but just saying how all of the online
stuff was going to leak out into reality
and
it's happening in front of our eyes so
that was just a tiny sampling
of what's going on and again any of
those instances if
even if and they're obviously not just
right like they're obviously not just no
matter what but even if
everything that those people believed
was right and good
if if we as a society say okay
if you feel oppressed if you
feel that you've been wronged or
whatever it might
be that you're allowed to take the law
into your own hands you're allowed to
stop traffic and attack people
and burn down restaurants and all that
well society's gone
so like we're kind of getting to that
precipice and we're going to really have
to think about that
okay so what i want to do for this third
segment now is actually just
break down numbers so if you got a pen
and paper
maybe keep it by your side so you can
make some notes on the time stamps here
and we're going to clip a whole bunch of
this stuff so you guys can get it out
there
and you know i have no doubt that the
people at media matters are going to
call me racist for reading statistics
alas i'm a glutton for punishment so
we're going to start with a quote from
the u.s
department of justice in the 75
largest u.s counties about 60 percent of
robbery and murder defendants are black
even though blacks comprise only 15
percent of the population
in those counties so that's just a
little sort of general thought on
crime now we can talk all about why
is it that more black people
proportionally are committing crime
that doesn't make you racist and and
actually this is something that larry
elder has talked about
for a long time that thomas soul was
talking about for decades
related to the family and the welfare
system and all of these things like you
guys if you're watching this show you've
heard about all of these things
unfortunately a lot of people don't hear
about these things
new york city.gov in new york city
blacks make
up 73 percent of all shooting victims
though they are 23 percent of the city's
population so that
generally is pointing to black on black
shootings i don't think we're going to
have any numbers immediately
from chicago michael maybe you can just
pull up something from this weekend
again
i think we did it the other day um but
in chicago
every week there are dozens and dozens
of black people shot
and they are shot by other black people
so you don't hear that
i would prefer that nobody be shot and i
don't care
actually if it's black people shooting
white people or white people shooting
black people
or whatever it might be but if these
people that purport to care about all of
these shootings
and care about dead children and all of
these things you'd think they would be
talking about that the only person on
mainstream media
who actually usually covers this stuff
is sean hannity and you're not going to
believe it they
call him a racist 34 people were shot in
chicago last weekend
three of them are dead that's according
to abc strange we didn't get any of
their names
now this is uh from statista and this is
uh this is super interesting in 2019 the
police killed 235 blacks
most of them armed or dangerous out of
1004 police
shooting victims overall that 25
ratio is actually less than what the
black crime rate would predict since
police shootings are a function
of the rate at which officers encounter
violent suspects so
did you catch that there so because
there are more violent suspects
who are black you would actually think
those numbers would be higher
but they're not as high again none of
these
numbers or statistics give me any
pleasure but do you think that these
things slightly go against the narrative
that cops are just out there shooting
people and specifically shooting people
over race
we've got more from the washington post
and this is what i read earlier but i
think this is
this is like the key one this is the key
one and when you read this to somebody
let them explain to you how the
washington post is lying here
and how that we have an epidemic which
is what they're telling us or a genocide
which is what they're telling us the
washington post database of fatal police
shootings in 2019
cites nine unarmed black victims
and 19 unarmed white victims of fatal
police shootings so that means
in 2019 nine black people who were
unarmed were killed by police
19 white people forget the race part of
that the idea that that
those numbers which are so low and yes
we all want them to be zero
we would but life is messy life is messy
okay and bad things happen and there are
bad people out there and everything else
but those numbers are extraordinarily
low actually
and in this case more white people were
shot so that should make these guys
happy
uh we've got something from the usa
today i think that's also somewhat
reputable
at least for now of the roughly 7 300
black homicide victims a year the number
of
unarmed black people shot by police
would constitute
constitute 0.2 percent of the cases so
there were about 7000 black people shot
and killed every year
the by and large that has nothing to do
with policing right it has to do with
more of what's going on
in chicago that i referenced earlier uh
and we've got another quote from
statista
officers make around 10 million arrests
a year and are tacked by deadly weapons
at a rate of 27
per day in a year only around 1 000
civilian deaths occur at the hands of
officers
the vast majority occurring in the face
of potentially
deadly attack so we know this right like
this is
generally where police officers try to
do the right thing and try not to shoot
on people we've all seen
so many videos of people breaking away
from arrest attacking police officers
and everything else um so i just think
these are important numbers to know
and here's the funny thing if you wanted
to the funny thing i guess it's the sad
thing or
it's just the reality thing um if you
wanted to solve any of these problems if
any of those numbers there
disturb you if you think any of that is
unjust or
that there's things that we could do
well then you would actually if you
really cared if you really cared not if
you were just here to burn down the
system
and not if you were just here to
violently
overthrow the evil american project
if you really want to do that then then
joe biden how about you read those
statistics
because you know joe biden it's funny
you've been in in public life for
47 years you were vice president to
america's first black president we're
such a racist country we had a two-term
black president
who was the hero of heroes right why
didn't you do anything about it
why didn't you do anything about it and
even obama issued a really awful
statement yesterday
and it's like i guess you didn't fix
racism man or why weren't you talking
about all of this stuff i mean that's
that's just that's just the depressing
reality
it's like these people are using this as
a way
of either ending the american experiment
or just
trying to get one party democratic rule
over
over everything but you know what let's
go into uh some stats related to
defunding the police right
because that is what sits beneath this
we're hearing from all of the social
justice warriors
we're hearing from the black lives
matter officials we're hearing from the
democrats that we have to defund
the police policing is racing racism
is racist we've got to get rid of it so
we've got a whole bunch of stuff here
on on defunding the police in
minneapolis
in december the minneapolis city council
unanimously approved a budget that
shifted approximately 8 million from the
police department
towards violent violence prevention and
other programs
between december 11 2020 and march 28
of this year murders in the city rose 46
okay so they took money away from
policing right they defunded the police
and then they got almost a 50
rise in murder i apologize for reading
you statistics
in portland another bastion of
progressive
utopia city commissioners voted in
mid-june to cut nearly
16 million from the police budget in
response to concerns about the use of
force and racial injustice
police statistics from joel high 2020
right after that when the city's budgets
cuts were made and this past february
the most recent data available show
homicides
skyrocketed 270 percent
compared to the same time last year we
defund the police cut their budget by 16
million dollars
and homicides rise by 270 percent
new york city a once great city that i
called home that i think is probably
the greatest city in in modern times
that is now just
an absolute awful dystopia the new york
city council voted in july to move
1 billion away 1 billion away from the
new york police department's budget and
instead moved the money to educational
and social services in 21
in 2021 murders in new york city are up
basically 12 percent year-to-date as of
march 21st
with 76 reported this year compared to
68 from 2020 according to new york
police department crime statistics the
number of shootings rose
40 percent in 2021 with 220 reported
as of march 21 compared to the 157
recorded during the same time last year
come back to me for just a sec here
before we get into los angeles i was in
new york city and i lived in new york
city from a little bit before 9 11. i
was there for 9 11 right out of college
and i lived in new york city until i
moved to los angeles in 2013.
i truly mean this i never once
in about 13 14 years almost of living in
new york city
ever felt unsafe no matter what time it
was where i was wandering around
never once felt unsafe i was back in new
york city about two weeks ago for the
greg gutfeld show
i was in midtown at fox news studios and
it felt unsafe it felt first off there
were every so many barricades everywhere
you know police and i don't have a
problem with the police in that regard
obviously but like just that there were
police everywhere it gives you this
feeling
that kind of something's not right that
there were no business people in midtown
right it's just a lot of people with
hats
and masks wandering around and everyone
kind of looks shady it did not
feel safe to me that was a very weird
thing to come back to and let's talk
about los angeles the city i'm in right
now
city leaders voted in july to cut the
police department budget by 150 million
reducing the number of
officers to a level not seen in more
than a decade
the lapd reported a 38 increase in
murders in 2020
despite the coronavirus mandates that
kept residents indoors
and for 2021 which we're only a couple
months into murders are
up 28 as of march 13th
with 77 killings reported this year to
date compared to the 60 reported
during the same time in 2020 statistics
show
the number of shooting victims nearly
doubled from 157 reported
through march 13 2020 compared to this
year's
303 and then let's do one in texas
because a lot of
la people are moving to texas and they
go to austin because that's the most
progressive of all cities even though
i'm hearing all sorts of bad things
related to homelessness and everything
else
in austin right now in august in august
austin city council unanimously voted to
cut roughly one third of the city's 434
million police
budget slashing just over 150 million
dollars
the funds were designated to be
redirected to social services in the
2021 fiscal budget
which started october 1st 2020
aggravated assaults report aggravated
assault reports were up 26
from 415 reported year to date in 2020
compared to 524
so far this year okay so that is a
smattering
[Music]
of evidence using statistics and data
of the cities that have cut policing
defunded the police
did what these activists want to do
and then what do you get in every single
case you get more crime
you get more murder you get more general
mayhem
and now think about this imagine if you
were a police officer or you were a
police officer in training right now
knowing that there is basically this
giant
mainstream movement to demonize you at
every turn
or that if you do what you are trained
to do or that you get into a messy
situation or whatever it might be
that you are going to basically be
attacked and destroyed
there are going to be a whole slew and
when we know this is already happening
that tons of good people are
self-selecting out of police work
because they don't it's not that they
don't feel it's safe they don't feel
that their own people
will protect them they feel like they
will be hampered i've talked about this
with plenty of police officers
uh over the last year when i've been to
some of these rallies and things
not only that but we know that tons of
police officers are are taking early
retirement
because they're like i just don't want
to deal with the headache anymore right
so we have such a series of cascading
problems
and you know i'm going to end with a
quote from mlk because i'm going to you
know
try to give you a little something at
the end to um
to take away to not feel the sort of
just like craziness
of the immediate moment and also to feel
some sense of hope of course
and i do feel hopeful but i i posted
something on locals this morning that
you know
one of the problems right now is that
there's a certain set of people who
believe that all the answers are
political so the people that are trying
to destroy all of this stuff
and actually virtually all of the
democrats who only have political
answers
to social problems political answers to
philosophic problems and existential
problems
their answers are always oh the
government can fix that problem for you
the government can fix depression the
government can fix crime
the government can fix that and this and
the other thing the government can make
sure that nobody's racist
like these things that the government
cannot do
well if we have a certain set of people
that believe that then what do the rest
of us do
right and i've talked about this before
because what what is it if you've got a
certain set of people that
that want government power for
everything and a certain set of people
that are like no we just don't want the
government
involved in our lives and we want to
have some autonomy and some
self-reliance and that sort of thing
what do we do because they're going to
constantly be encroaching on us
and i think for now the thing that you
can do is focus
on local communities focus on your life
focus on your
family i think it's the only thing we
can do for now
i don't know that there's a macro answer
right now focus on building
new technologies and new companies and
not being so reliant on all of this
stuff and and hopefully
you know if you do pay a little
attention to the news uh sharing some
things with people to help wake them up
because that that's our chance right now
the cha
the the chance doesn't come through
politics like the answer to what's going
on doesn't come through politics right
now because what
would turn this around in a political
sense right like
there was a chance actually i mean this
is an odd reality
there was a chance and that chance would
have been a donald trump second term to
really
break these things that chance is now
gone okay it's it's not coming back
we're not
we don't have a time machine ain't got a
flux capacitor or
1.21 gigawatts so there is no sort of
political force that can that can fight
this right now
but it can be done at a smaller level
ron desantis doing a fine job in florida
right fighting it so that's where we
have to kind of focus
and and again focus on you this is very
much what my next book is about which i
think you're going to dig and
we'll have some announcements on that in
the next couple weeks but i will end
with a quote and i i hope you feel
that uh for all the craziness right now
that you got a little something sane
uh for today and this quote is from mlk
i thought that would be appropriate from
martin luther king jr
darkness cannot drive out darkness only
light can do that
hate cannot drive out hate only love can
do that
all right it's a little lofty it's a
little pollyannish
but i think that's what our chances are
our chance is you guys
that really is the truth uh part two of
my interview with chef andrew gruel who
became one of the
true fighters for freedom in california
in the midst of all these lockdowns
uh is up right now on youtube and of
course the full episode is up
ad free at localrubinreport.locals.com
have a great day everybody stay sane get
offline when you need to
eat some good food hug someone you love
that's it
see you tomorrow